[Music]
and good luck to astro mejía with his
brief information for today, tuesday, august 3,
a vigil is organized in honor
of the people of nh and tonight it begins
at 6 pm at the police memorial
park near zayani hualapai east
officer died after a chase
on interstate 15 last week
michael bay's funeral is this friday
a man is dead after a shooting
in cardiff and sparta around
8 p.m.
las vegas metropolitan police said two
men started  to fight later one
pulled out a gun and shot him after the
shooting fled the scene the victim was
transferred to liu in continua where
later the medical personnel pronounced him
dead if you have more information do not hesitate
to contact crime stop at 70 23
85  55 55 the clark county fire department is
hosting a
vaccination clinic today from 10 am to
noon this station is
east of the valley on was in
near  [ __ ] street the clinic offers drive-
thru services and accepts
walk-ins for the vaccine
as long as they are over 12 and now
we turn to the weather forecast we are in for
a hot day with temperatures
reaching 110 degrees for today there is
an extreme heat alert for some
sectors of the valley that extends until
tomorrow we will continue with temperatures
exceeding 110 degrees for the rest
of the week
remember to drink plenty of water and not be
exposed to the sun for a long period of
time have a nice day of health to
hector mejía this was your brief
disney informative in spanish
[Music]